What is the most important journal paper published in chemistry
during your lifetime?
I have no idea. Um, there are a number of papers,
which I think are obviously very landmark papers,
I suppose. The first in my lifetime,
that was really all my scientific lifetime was the fact that
Xenon could react with flooring or PTF sex,
which really caused a big shift in people's thinking,
I think the publication,
the paper about 60 the molecule,
buckyballs also changed. People's thinking quite a lot,
but many of these key papers in chemistry
have been
once the people have understood them,
they become almost obvious.
But I think if I should be honest,
and this was paper that was published in 1952.
So when I was four and a half years old,
so it was before my scientific lifetime,
I would say probably the most important paper was the paper by cricket and
Watson about the structure of DNA. In the sense,
it gave us more understanding about the
mechanism of life and ideas on
hereditary, how to cure diseases and so on than anything else.
But I can't say that I really took it in though.
I can remember as a teenager reading a newspaper article about the
structure of DNA,
it was probably when Crick and Watson got their Nobel prize in the early
sixties. And I got really excited about that and told my father,
this is what I wanted to do when I grew up.
How do we know the shape and arrangement of complex molecules?
The most obvious way is by using x-ray crystallography,
which can tell you the position of atoms and molecules.
It can't tell you whether they bonded together or not,
but because that depends on the electrons,
but it can tell you where one atom is relative to another. Next year,
2014 is the international year of crystallography.
And so we'll probably be doing several videos about it then.
So keep watching for that.
The most exciting development is a technique called scanning tunneling
microscopy, where by moving a tip,
very sharp tip across the surface,
you can actually feel the shape of a molecule.
Rather like somebody who's blind can feel the shape of
something on the table, even though they can't see it.
And that is revealing the shapes of molecules in really
quite a lot of detail.
And perhaps that's the most unexpected development,
the whole of my scientific career, the idea that you can actually image Molly.
Why did you choose chemistry over the other sciences when you were in high
school or college?
I'm ashamed to say that I only had one school term,
which is about eight weeks of biology in the whole of my career.
And looking back on it it's much more,
what would now be called nature study than modern biology.
I then studied chemistry and physics and my father and
grandfather were physicists. So I wanted to become a physicist.
I wasn't good enough at maths.
I had a near photographic memory as a child.
So learning chemistry was very easy. I was,
must've been a pupil for, from hell for my chemistry teacher.
I talk to my friends all the time in the class,
but I could answer every question like that, except once.
And I never seen a bigger smile on the face of a teacher than that.
Do you remember what the question was? No. That one didn't get photographed.
What is one discovery that you think will come after your lifetime and how will
it change our lives?
That's very interesting question.
And the answer is that if we could predict what the discovery would be,
it probably wouldn't change our lives. All that much.
A lot is made of quantum computing,
which people now in theory knows what it should do,
but in practice have a moving towards it.
But haven't got very far what might happen even in my lifetime is
the manufacturing of synthetic organisms.
So-called synthetic biology in which one could
create bacteria.
And this could transform the way that we make chemicals,
because you could make a bacterium,
which within reason could convert this compound into that one.
You'll never make a bacterium that can convert late into gold,
but you could one organic compound into another.
What is the highest possible atomic number for an element?
If you work for the international union of pure and applied chemistry,
they don't send
999 because they worked out a system for naming elements up through
999.
I think the answer is that these elements become more
and more unstable as you go up. There's still some argument,
whether elements are 119 hundred and 20 will be synthesized anytime
soon,
there is some suggestion that they will be so-called islands of stability.
That is you go through a lot unstable elements and then you will come to some
really stable elements. And quite a long time ago,
nearly 40 years ago,
somebody published a paper in which they looked at some mineral called
Micah. That's the one that comes in sheets,
rather like sheets of glass and found some strange spots,
which they interpreted as the decay of super-heavy elements.
Everyone got really excited, turned out to be rubbish.
How has the introduction of computers changed the way you think about or do
chemistry?
When our department,
I wasn't working here got the first computer that people ordinary users could
use and program,
I thought it was a bit boring and didn't want to use it.
But then I found that I could predict the spectrum of the molecules that I was
making. And I got really hooked.
I spent a thousand minutes a week of computing time.
That was the limit and the computer terminal sort of chunk the way in a
little conservatory in the department.
And I would go and visit it every few minutes.
It's been enormously important.
I think in the way that people publish chemistry.
Very few people now have paper copies of journals.
They publish everything electronically,
get them down as PDF files.
And it's also had a huge effect with people collaborating via
instant messaging, very email and so on.
So that one can talk to somebody on the other side of the world and do an
experiment together.
As a chemist. What motivates you to keep going.
Doing research is to some extent,
almost like an addiction,
you keep on needing more and more to keep going.
I suppose that the reason I really keep going is because I
enjoy it.
And because nature that is what's
around us rather than the journal nature is so fascinating
because even quite boring experiments
can turn out to be really exciting.
And everything that we discover
about nature is clever than we expect.
And what's your biggest disappointment.
I'm not sure what my biggest disappointment is.
I think scientists tend to live in the present.
It's difficult to say.
I have a friend who worked in industry who did some
experiments with rating carbon and produced a red solution,
which we now know is C 60,
but he didn't have time to analyze it because his industrial required something
else. So he could have discovered [inaudible] long before other people.
I don't think in my career,
I feel that I have overlooked various things.
I suppose there are a number of occasions where I've said an idea was stupid
and then somebody else has gone and done it and shown that it works.
But in that case, I think one can just laugh and say,
well, they brighten me and be pleased that they've got the thing to work.
What is your proudest scientific achievement? And why?
I think one really gets quite excited
about whatever is the current experiments you're doing.
There are one or two things which I have done,
which are not big achievements, but I think without being arrogant,
that I, I was quite clever to think of them.
Even though the actual idea was not voluminous importance.
Many years ago, my professor took a sabbatical year.
He took a whole term off to do experiments and he worked really hard,
but he couldn't understand his results. And I came and sat on the,
um, lab stool next to him and made the suggestion,
which explained everything.
And of course I felt quite clever turns out that the
experiment was very little importance.
I doubt if anybody has read the paper about it for nearly 40
years, but I still feel quite pleased.
But I think in the end,
people like me, senior scientists are a bit like parents.
And the thing that really makes me proud is when I see my former
students, my former post-docs doing really well in science,
getting prizes, becoming professors themselves. And that's,
I suppose,
is in some ways by far the biggest reward for being a scientist
that I learned from terrific scientists before me.
And I've been able to pass at least a bit of that on to future generations.
And perhaps through these videos, I can pass a little bit on.
[Inaudible].